yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
Jessica Jones the wisecracking hard
drink in private investigating superhero
is back for a kick-ass second season and
with Avengers infinity war just around
the corner the show has some awesome
Easter eggs and teasers for the Avengers
epic showdown with Thanos plus there are
some cool deep cut Marvel references
which I'll be explaining my new Marvel
giveaway is also starting for all my
subscribers so keep watching I'll have
more details on that later obviously
there are some spoilers for season 2 so
take care if you're not caught up
through some great hat tips to Avengers
infinity war previous Marvel movie team
ups and the comics when Jessica lets
herself into Oscars apartment to look
for clues I need to find his young son
Vito awake nobody called toys in your
room you want to show me do you know
what Captain America
I've got his action figure but I lost
the shield so I made him but no one
however myself I just glued a magnet to
it so it looks like the real one
capture the schooler this one doesn't
have to take down an Hamid so I don't
know there's quite a lot of references
here so let's break them down
feetoes holding a Captain America figure
dressed in what looks like his classic
colors which we saw him were in Civil
War this isn't the first time we've seen
how popular cap is with kids in
Jessica's world as in season 1 we saw a
young child wearing a Captain America
costume in the park when Jessica first
tried to abduct kilgrave back to this
season Vito's line about losing cap
shield is a delightful nod to the fact
that Captain America abandoned his
shield at the end of Civil War following
his full-on battle with Iron Man as
shield doesn't belong to you
you don't deserve it my father made that
you
[Music]
but Vito's words are also a shout-out to
Avengers infinity war where we'll likely
see cap without a shield for a period of
time and get this manna shooter but
thanks to a certain genius by the name
of Shuri and some super cutting edge
work and in tech infinity war will also
debut caps epic new arm shields and
frankly I cannot wait by the way I talk
in detail about caps new gauntlets
including how they compares the comics
in my video about caps new shield now
the fact that video has created a
replacement shield for his Captain
America figure using a magnet is also a
hat tip to both the MCU and the comics
where we've seen cap throw his shield
around and call it back using magnetic
elements video also says that caps real
shield is cooler than the one he's made
and adds but this one doesn't have to
take down any aliens
well if Vito loves caps multicolored
shield which he used to kick alien
guitar ebert in the first Avengers movie
just wait till he gets an eyeful of his
new monochrome shield in action in
infinity war where it will most
definitely be used to take down some
major alien threats and the likes of
phalluses Black Order and those four
armed creatures called outriders and
then this video's question to Jessica do
you know Captain America Jessica's
hesitation in replying here is a hint to
the comics the MC news jessica certainly
does know off Steve Rogers and the
Avengers just like the rest of New York
for example in season 1 she referred to
the flag waver and the big green guy but
it's in Marvel's comics where Jessica
Jones actually does know Captain America
personally in early issues of the alias
comics Jessica inadvertently captures
Captain America's secret identity on
film while she's on a case for a client
when she realizes she's been set up to
catch cap on camera Jessica keeps the
tape safe until she can hand it over to
Steve Rogers himself who praises her for
helping him and tells her to get in
touch if she needs anything or decides
to be a superhero again and in the
what-if series Jessica not only joined
the Avengers but she actually ended up
marrying Steve Rogers on top of that in
certain comics the mantle of Captain
America is taken on by Jessica's
daughter with Luke Cage Danielle if you
say with great power comes great
responsibility
I saw a pair of Anya Jessica also
dropped several sardonic references to
spider-man during season 2 including
plays on the line with great power comes
great responsibility you're always
saying how powers are good but you were
wrong with great power comes great
mental illness and puns on Peter Parker
spidey sense I know she's in trouble
because you're scrotie sense goddamn
Mike of course spider-man is part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe now but even
before his first MCU appearance and
Civil War the creators of Jessica Jones
were already sneaking Easter eggs to the
web crawling superhero into their first
season yes if you look really carefully
you can see an ice-cream cart which was
selling spider-man ice cream as for this
season's more overt shoutouts to Spidey
they're a callback to Jessica's comic
book history with our friendly
neighborhood spider-man
given TV Jessica's sarcastic tone when
she talks about Spidey it's actually
quite funny that in the comics her dad
didn't seem to have a very high opinion
of the young web slinger either as for
Jessica's various mentions of
spider-man's famous mantra in the show
that has a special significance if you
dive back into the comics in the books
after Jessica got her superpowers it was
seeing Spidey take on the villainous
ant-man at her school that inspired her
to become a hero like him and when she
tells Spidey what an enormous impact he
had on her life he shares with her the
saying that he lives his life by with
great power there must also come great
responsibility Jessica then tells him
that she'll teach the meaning of those
words to her daughter Danielle who was I
mentioned earlier and some comics grows
up to take on the role of Captain
America and in addition to that it's
spider-man who encourages Jessica to go
back to being a superhero again I was
buying whiskey at this liquor store and
this guy came in
he was all jumpy and dopesick and I knew
he was there to rob the place the
service lady said I don't have spidey
sense and that's far from the only
connection between Peter Parker and
Jessica in the comics as not only did
they go to the same high school but she
also had quite a crush on him
in fact she was about to ask him out
when things started to go radioactive
for Peter now while it would be fun to
see Tom Hollands new spider-man swing
through Jessica Jones's TV world were
very unlikely to ever see that happen
however given the pair's rich history in
the comics I'm sure we'll get plenty
more Spidey related references like the
ones I've talked about here in future
shows and Jessica Jones doesn't just
limit its connections to the Marvel
movie universe but it also has plenty of
references to Marvel's Netflix shows
when one of the cops interrogating Jess
says I know you people like to team up
it's a nod to Jessica's last appearance
in the defenders where she joined forces
with daredevil Luke Cage and iron fist
against the hand plus it's also a
callback to the first season of Jessica
Jones where she worked together with
Luke Cage who offered his support again
to her at the very end of the defenders
series trusty and in touch Jess you got
friends one of them isn't home and the
cops words also foreshadow Alyssa's
suggestion to Jessica that they team up
to do good and the way they work
together to save the family whose car
crashed with a truck carrying chemicals
has happened to Jessica's family in the
comics on top of that the cops lied
about superhero team-ups is also linked
to the Avengers movies as well as
various incarnations the Avengers in the
comic books some of which featured
Jessica Jones as part of the famous
group of superheroes oh and when
Jessica's former boyfriend sterling
finds out the ten middle name is
Campbell that's a hat tip to the comics
where Jessica's original surname was
Campbell until she was adopted by the
Jones family after her biological family
died in a car accident
speaking of sterling one of the guys he
threatens him was a necklace with the
number 23 on it and asked about Jessica
can she fly which is a clear shout-out
to the issue 23 of alias where Jessica
starts to fly but ends up crash landing
in the river though later she flies
again and manages to stop a robbery by
the former P I turned
the scorpion now what did you think of
season 2 of Jessica Jones and did you
spot any other cool MCU or comic book
Easter eggs be sure to leave me a
comment with your thoughts and subscribe
for your chance to win a cool marble
Funko pop the winner from my last Marvel
giveaway is on screen now so if that's
you private message me with your details
so I can send out your prize and while
you're waiting for my next Marvel video
tap the screen to check out my latest
theories Easter eggs and superhero
videos thanks for watching and see you
next time you PK movie lovers